our next speaker is David Goldman he
last spoke for the college on campus in
the spring of 2017 during his his
residency on campus as a Pulliam
journalism fellow and I should mention
that David speaks for the college both
on land and at sea he was the speaker on
our Alaska cruise in 2016 when he's not
busy speaking for Hillsdale he is a
columnist for the Asia Times where he
writes the Spengler column he also
writes regularly on politics for
numerous other outlets including PJ
media and the Claremont Review of Books
and he doesn't only write on politics
he's also the classical music critic for
tablet magazine he's directed research
departments at various investment banks
and he's been a consultant for the
National Security Council and the
Department of Defense he's a senior
fellow of the London Institute for
Policy Studies and a member of the Board
of Advisors of American affairs who's
editor we heard from this morning he's
also the author of a book how
civilizations die and why Islam is dying
too
you will be speaking today on the
subject of China and Russia would you
please welcome to the podium David
Goldman
[Applause]
Tim thank you for that very kind
introduction I can't tell you how
gratified I am to be among you today and
how grateful I am to Hillsdale College
for inviting me this is a unique group
of people you're precious and important
and it's a privilege to spend time with
you
my only trepidation is I have to follow
one of the greatest acts in history
Larry Oren that's intimidating but I'll
do my best the one theme I'd like to
keep in mind as we talk about the
formidable strategic challenge that
China especially and in a different way
Russia posed to us is that Russia and
China are motivated by insecurity and
fear America has inherent strengths
which they do not and our greatest
danger is not our lack of capacity or
lack of strength but our complacency
China is a phenomenon unlike anything in
economic history if I can leave you with
one number to think about it's that the
average Chinese now consumes 17 times as
much as he or she did back in 1987 it's
a difference between driving a car and
riding a bicycle it's the difference
between indoor plumbing and a dirt floor
in an outhouse it's an absolutely
remarkable and sudden change which has
lifted what was a backward country into
the first rank of world economies and
really has no comparison just one other
thing to keep in mind China has in the
last 35 years moved approximately 600
million people from the countryside to
the cities that's the equivalent of all
of Europe from the Ural Mountains to the
Atlantic Ocean and to do that they built
the equivalent of a new London Berlin
Rome Glasgow Helsinki Naples Lyon to
accommodate them and of course as you
move people who spent whose ancestors
spent millennia in the tedious monotony
of traditional life and bring them into
the industrial world their productivity
explodes nothing like that's ever
happened in history now where do we
stand with respect to China
economists use something called
purchasing power parity in other words
if you take a bunch of dollars into
China you can buy a whole lot more for
it than you can in the United States so
adjusted for that the Chinese economy is
already bigger than ours if you keep it
in dollar terms we're still bigger but
they are certainly gaining on us and
sometime the next 80 8 to 10 years
they'll be at parity so unlike any
competitor we've had in the past we have
an economy which is roughly
par with ours now most important thing
to remember about Russia and China is
they are empires based on coercion of
unwilling peoples where the United
States created a great nation out of
willing immigrants who came here because
they want to be part of the United
States as individuals
China and Russia conquered peoples
different ethnicities and different
languages and kept them in by force so
whereas we have a pluribus unum they
still have a pluribus ploor of us except
for a dictatorship sitting on top now
China started out as you can see as a
relatively small area it's kind of like
the Continental Republic which occupied
a tiny part of the continent it took
them about 1500 years to reach their
borders but by around the ninth century
China had reached the natural frontiers
and didn't expand after that they can't
expand over the Himalayas to India to
their extreme west is desert and their
East of course is the ocean so China is
not an expansionist power but it's never
been a unified country China Chinese
culture is unique very different from
ours China has two languages that as a
written system of characters which
requires approximately the first seven
years of elementary education working
four hours a day with an ink brush and
ink pot and paper to master to be
literate in China used to reads to the
several thousand characters needed to
read a school textbook or a newspaper is
approximately a six or seven year
exercise for Chinese kids that's how the
Chinese are socialized China had a
literacy rate of about 30 percent at
2,000 years ago many times higher than
Europe only exceeded by the the Jewish
literacy rate at the time
this generation is the first where the
majority of Chinese understand a common
language because of the centralization
of the state mass media and so forth but
they still speak very different
languages Cantonese and Mandarin are as
different as Finnish and French in Hong
Kong you'll see Chinese screaming at
each other and broken English because
one speaks Mandarin either speaks
Cantonese and they don't have a word in
common so that state is always
inherently unstable because it's held
together by a common Imperial culture
and by the tax collector in Beijing
China is like a bag of very powerful
oppositely charged magnets held together
by superglue it looks very stable but it
inherently isn't and in fact in the
memory of living Chinese you had an era
of national division warlordism civil
war starvation degradation the century
of humiliation that began with the opium
wars in 1848 and ended with a communist
revolution 1947 was one in which civil
war is claimed in the 19th century one
claimed between fifty and a hundred
million lives World War two twenty-five
million Chinese died so the terror of
return to conditions that are not far
from the living memory of many Chinese
is still a specter that haunts the
Chinese leadership Russia similarly from
Kevin Roos conquered its East conquered
the Caucasus and parts of Persia with a
result that Russia has a Muslim
population that amounts to a seventh of
its citizens their restive their
problematic China also has a much
smaller Muslim population and it's West
that's the Uighur is there
twelve to fourteen million of them there
are turkey people there Muslim they
don't really speak Chinese but Jinjiang
province the westernmost province of
China is inhabited by a majority of them
and it's a continuous source of fear to
the Chinese state so you have inherently
unstable countries in the case of Russia
Russia has always been a set of failed
projects of Eastern expansion supported
by the collection of taxes on the
industrial part and the West there's
always been a tendency for the West to
try to secede and move towards Europe
that was one of the causes of World War
one and it and for the east to break off
so a country like Russia has never
let itself to kind gentle and rational
rulers by comparison to his predecessors
Vladimir Putin is certainly one of the
least blood xxx thirsty at least
murderous rulers that Russia has had in
its long and difficult history it's
variable to talk about democracy in
Russia I wish them well but the imperial
system has lent itself towards a
centralized dictatorship in which a
single man sitting in the Kremlin has to
contend with centrifugal forces which
require often a bloody response most
important thing to know about China the
Chinese don't like China China Chinese
have a dual existence if you walk down
the street in Beijing you see people who
dress very drab lling who show no
emotion in public who do their best not
to draw attention to themselves but if
you go to a Chinese wedding or Chinese
home or even a restaurant on Sunday
where families gather they're loud
they're bumptious they laugh the kids
run riot their real existence as a
family existence that's why by the way
the Lunar New Year is so important which
is occurring right now during the Lunar
New Year the Chinese every year have the
largest migration in human history
four billion long-distance journeys are
undertaken because every Chinese
wherever they are will travel thousands
of miles to be with their family in the
West in the Roman tradition we have a
concept of rights and privileges you
serve in the army you pay your taxes and
the Roman State has certain obligations
to the privileges of rights in return
for the obligations that you've filled
the state that there
been a concept in China the tax
collector in Beijing rules by whip you
do everything that the emperor asks you
to do and you hope that he rewards you
but there's no sense of anything
deserved the idea that the state is held
together by a common interest as Cicero
said or by a common love as st.
Augustine said is unknown in China the
emperor is a necessary evil
China's avidin had an emperor for three
thousand years well they didn't have an
ampere they killed each other it's all
very well to lecture the Chinese about
the benefits of Western democracy but
most Chinese will say we need an emperor
because we'd kill each other and when we
didn't have an emperor or it didn't have
a strong Emperor during the century of
hema humiliation that's exactly what
happened so we prefer to have a strong
Emperor and from the standpoint of most
Chinese this imperial dynasty this
communist party dynasty has brought
about a golden age it's the first time
in Chinese history where no one's afraid
of starving to death no one's afraid of
a warlord coming through and raping the
women and burning the crops there's
security and prosperity relative to
Chinese history it's a very good period
so for the time being the regime has a
great deal of support and as deplorable
as I find the practices of the Chinese
regime which as a totalitarian entity is
more comprehensive and more intrusive
than Hitler or Stalin could ever imagine
being as deplorable as I find it I think
the prospects for transforming it by our
good offices are for the time being
negligible so what does the dynasty try
to do to stay in power well the first
thing they said as well China's basic
historical problems got a lot of people
but not much arable land big country
mostly mountains in deserts so
you've every time you had a prosperity
would an increase in population there
were too many peasants you know peasant
rebellion and the dynasty would fall so
we have a one-child policy and we
evacuate the countryside no peasants no
rebellion biggest social engineering
exercise in human history deeply
motivated by the dynasty's desire to
perpetuate itself in power instead of a
family-based imperial dynasty you have a
party based meritocracy
when I say meritocracy we say No Child
Left Behind the Chinese say only the
exceptional survive one of the problems
the Chinese have in understanding
American politics is if you're in the
Chinese leadership you come from a track
of high exam scores starting with 12
which means you haven't met a stupid
person since you were in junior high
school and the idea that democracy is
can frequently advance stupid people
we're entitled to do that if we wish to
doesn't make any sense them so they're
very clever people
the one thing she Jinping president of
China cannot do is get his child into
Peking University the equivalent of
Harvard or Stanford
unless that child scored sufficiently
high on the exam Harvard's easy can buy
your way in by building you can't do
that in China the meritocracy in that
respect is absolute so the Chinese
Communist Party is not a particularly
efficient or good organization but
others a lot of very smart people in it
and along with ensuring internal
stability at all costs they wish to make
China impregnable from the outside I'll
get to this in a second I don't know how
long it's been since you've heard the
term South China Sea but it's kind of
dropped out of the newspapers in the
last year it's become a Chinese lake the
Chinese have made clear they'll go to
war with the South China Sea
why will they do that this is Chinese
proverb kill the chicken for the
instruction of
monkey the Chinese concern is not the
South China Sea so much as Taiwan
China's terrified that one rebel
province for example Taiwan could set a
precedent for a centrifugal forces that
the party couldn't control so the
adhesion of Taiwan to the Chinese state
the Chinese emperor is for the Chinese
Communist Party an existential matter
for the future existence of the state
they will go to war over it and by
demonstrated their willingness to fight
over the South China Sea they're saying
in effect off fortiori will we fight all
the more viciously over Taiwan or or
Tibet I'm going to skip over this this
this is the the in terms of the Chinese
economy this is the key slide it's a bit
it's a bit complicated so it could be
just a moment it's worth your while to
stare at it for a second
China does something that the Japanese
do the Koreans do all the Asians do
which is to massively subsidized capital
investment in heavy industry from the
Asian standpoint a steel mill a
semiconductor fabrication plant big
industrial investment is a public good
the same way that we'd look at a highway
an airport or something else that we'd
pay for out of public funds so the
result of Chinese subsidies for heavy
industry is that they've pushed us out
of any major capital intensive
manufacturing that's the decisive thing
the Japanese we're doing it and that's
why we forced the Japanese to build car
plants in the United States under the
Reagan administration but Japan is still
very small compared to the United States
the difference is that the Chinese are
doing this in an economy which is
roughly our size so it has a massive
impact so what I feel here is the
capital intensity of
all the companies in the major Chinese
stock index and the MSCI China stock
index versus their return on equity the
more capital-intensive the higher the
return in equity in the United States if
you look at the S&P 500 the slope is in
the other direction more capital
intensive industries are less profitable
and the trend the distortion of global
investment by Athan and particularly
Chinese subsidies for heavy industry has
led to a stripping of capital out of
heavy industry it's not that people
prefer financial assets to real assets
is that the Chinese have pushed us out
of it and that's why we've lost so much
ground in terms of industry
I think Julia's crime fed a similar
slide to this I published this one in
the Wall Street Journal in an article I
wrote jointly with Henry Purcell just as
Trump was elected so China's share of
high tech exports has risen from about
5% in 1999 to about 25% of present all
Americas has gone for about 20% to about
7% that's not a desirable situation what
it means practically is that we can't
build a military aircraft without
Chinese chips that's a national security
issue so looking forward China wants to
move into dominance in high-tech
industry and when you look at this one
belt one road plan to dominate industry
through Eurasia
it is like the Japanese greater Asian
prosperity sphere but it has a different
spin for my sins I spent some years as a
development economist and the main thing
you notice in so-called developing
economies is they think they don't
develop because 40 percent of the people
are outside the formal economy they're
in the so-called underground economy
they have little market stalls or
hustles or whatever and there
incredible they live unproductive lives
they sit waiting for someone to come
along and buy a leader of cooking oil
huge amounts of wasted effort what the
Chinese have done is to rip out the
social structure of village life and
globalize it China is nothing like the
Japanese economy there's no comparison
there's some comparisons but remember
Japan above all wanted to maintain its
social structure it protected
agriculture a protected small retail
protected small business so in the
Japanese economy you have a few great
companies with global capacity sitting
on top of very backward protected
inefficient economy trying to suck
people out of the villages put them in
the cities they're equivalent to of
Amazon Alibaba will take over the entire
labor of Chinese villages a broadband
stretching all over the country so some
intrapreneur and a village will figure
out something that village can make then
the whole village works for him they've
they've intentionally ripped out the
social structure and that's why they
don't have the same constraints as Japan
and what they propose to do is repeat
that experiment throughout all of Asia
to sign off' I everywhere from Turkey
through to Southeast Asia a couple of
years ago I'll tell you a story I've
visited Huawei headquarters Huawei is
the great telecommunications company
biggest in the world hardly exists at a
dozen years ago now it's got 70% of the
world market in telecommunications how
they do what they cut prices and they
got subsidies from the government they
did it dirty and they have a campus that
looks like a science fiction movie makes
Stanford look like a slum and to get the
tour I arranged to have a Latin American
ambassador and his team come with me so
I could I did that because I wanted to
see it but after the tour of their
exhibition all which took three hours
and you know the incredible technologies
on display the Chinese Sat these Latin
Americans down Atlanta theater they said
if you turn your economy over to us we
will make you like China will put in
telecommunications we'll put in
broadband will bring in e-commerce we'll
bring in finance and you will be like
China to the Latin Americans didn't take
them up on them but the Turks did turkey
plans to be a cashless society in five
years the Chinese telecommunications
companies are rebuilding the Turkish
broadband network
the reason turkey feels comfortable
cocking a snook at the United States is
because they've given up on the West
there the Western economic problems of
China and the impact of this global plan
is felt all over the world in former
allies or former NATO members orienting
towards China and giving us all kinds of
all kinds of trouble Russia
it's quadrupled its energy exports to
China totally dependent on China
economically China likes the idea of had
to land at based energy imports just in
case the United States gets it into our
head to interfere with Seabourn energy
traffic so Russia know with what a
twelfth a population of China tiny
economy relatively is really although
Chinese in Ruffins certainly don't like
each other is very dependent on China
China's has a high-speed rail network
where you have trains going at 200 miles
an hour so that you know you could
easily live in Tampa and work in Miami
it's had huge productivity effects and
they're proposing to build them all over
Southeast Asia Thailand used to be an
American a lot is being absorbed into
the Chinese economy Thailand is an
agricultural country they've figured out
that with high-speed trains they can
become the truck garden for China they
do all of the fresh fruits and
vegetables so China's being observed
islands being absorbed and so forth
now the most dangerous idea are
dangerous misconception about China is
that they can't innovate I've heard
people say they can only copy but they
they can't invent things well who do you
think invented gunpowder then magnetic
compass the clock and movable type the
culture certainly can invent now of
course it's a much more conformist
culture on average Chinese are less
likely to be innovators but there's so
lots of them and they're in a ver R&D
spending goes going to catch up with
hours they're already producing four
times as many stem bachelor's degrees
and twice as many stem PhDs granted some
of them are a low quality but a lot of
them aren't a lot of the Chinese PhDs
are terrific I've worked for several
years for a Chinese owned investment
bank out of Hong Kong we took some of
these God's public and they were real
go-getting innovators there was good as
anything in silicon a Silicon Valley so
the single biggest deficiency we have
the United States in my view is not the
industrial base that's easier to deal
with than the lack of scientific and
engineering education I think six or
seven percent of our kids major in
engineering
China's you know 30 40 percent that's
the real problem we've got so Julius
already mentioned some of these things
so the problem we have in my view is not
so much that we have tariffs with trade
agreements whatever we have a massive
distortion of the global system by
Chinese Industrial Policy there's such a
large economy it has that gravitational
effect not only that the Chinese also
play a very dirty one of the things the
Trump administration broke up brought up
and mentioned in its national security
strategy is forced technology transfer
Intel wants to get access to the Chinese
market biggest chip market in the world
the Chinese say that's fine you teach us
how to do everything you know how to
do and will let you work will give you
access now for the standpoint of Intel
stock price in the next five to ten
years that's a pretty good deal I mean
it may not be good for the United States
but it's good for Intel stock price if
we were to say excuse me we're not going
to let you transfer technology to China
with a gun to your head the first people
to scream about it would be the Intel's
in the Texas Instruments of the world
because it wouldn't be good for their
stock price and the CEO is supposed to
be worried about is about the stock
price
I'm a fruit trader on the free market er
but national security sometimes
supervenes this would be such a case if
you look at where investment goes in R&D
this is this
I'm not going to burden you with more of
the data but it it you can see that we
had a lot of investment in computers
peripherals telecommunication equipment
that's basically zeroed out in the last
few years and virtually all of the all
of the investment is god of software so
we've conceded to Asia not just China
Taiwan and Korea as well and Japan the
actual manufacturing such that as I said
we can't put a warplane of the year
without asian ships and since the
security of ships encryption is built
into the chip itself that is a serious
national security concern so what do we
do about it I don't care whether
industrial policy is a good idea a bad
idea or not or the above we Americans
can't do it as Americans we have a
radical conception of individual liberty
we are not good at being collectivists
Germany has industrial policy culturally
they can deal with it we cannot if we're
gonna win this one we've got to win it
the American Way and that radical
commitment Liberty no other country in
the world told people they've got a
right to pursue happiness
to make of themselves whatever they
wanted what we are best at is innovation
my life experience is that in the 1970s
all the smart people thought that Russia
was going to win the Cold War all the
economists thought Russia had a great
economy including the CIA economists
including pole Samuelson the author of
the standard textbook that's what
everybody said and then by 1989 we
realized the whole Russian economy was
one gigantic piece of junk a Matta Zola
been an 8-track tape player it was
worthless it was actually a negative
worth because the environmental cleanup
was worth more than the scrap value of
whatever they were producing what
happened in the interim what happened
was the greatest wave of industrial
innovation in American history we
invented fast light and small and cheap
microchips we invented sensors that
didn't exist before we invented the
semiconductor laser and we did virtually
all of this and after the Defense
Advanced Research Projects Agency and
NASA in cooperation with the great
corporate laboratories a Henrique
Rochelle whom Julia's crime mentioned
before and the excuse me the honor to
co-author a number of articles with him
he was then head of RCA labs they
invented CMOS chip manufacturing why
were American avionics so fabulous
totally crushed the Russian Air Force
Russian knew they couldn't win a war
against us by 1983 and 1984 when in the
1978 they were pretty confident in 1978
was when we put the chips into an f15
that made look down radar possible and
then the Israelis uses them in 1982 when
the Bekaa Valley turkey shoot when they
wiped out the Syrian Air Force don't
know how many ever remember that but it
was American avionics versus Russian
avionics and it was aided in nothing
basically
and the Russians looked at and said we
have a problem
we turned the Russian economy into junk
by creating an economy that hadn't
existed before that was the Reagan
economy the fortune 500 lost employment
during the 1980s corruption comes from
monopolies the monopolies were all
ruined new companies don't ever heard of
sprang up to commercialize these
technologies and we had the least
corrupt economy because we had
challengers doing new things taking
market share away from the existing
entrenched interests 1983 I wrote a memo
for the National Security Council
arguing that the Strategic Defense
Initiative would pay for itself that the
impact of the new technologies that we
were researching once they were
commercialized to generate more tax
revenue than we'd spent on the R&D when
you do basic R&D you don't know the
outcome the reason seamos chip
manufacturing came about was because
somebody at the Pentagon thought it
would be great for fighter pilots that
have their own weather forecasting model
in the cockpit no one realized what they
could do would look down radar we got
the semiconductor laser and because
thought of the Pentagon wanted a lot of
a battlefield at nights for a night
warfare and that produced consequences
that ripple through the economy that
nobody could imagine that's what we
haven't been doing our hearts grew fat
start him with a Clint administration we
felt we were so powerful we didn't have
to do these things anymore so the
investment went into the internet bubble
of the of the 1990s where the whole
world will be based on downloading
movies and watching pornography that was
going to be the economy of the future
I'm a market guy the one thing markets
though cannot do is divorce themselves
from culture long term expectations are
cultural and when we have an ass
security requirement where we have to go
to the frontier of physics to develop
weapons that will protect us and be
better than the other fellas that's when
you get the best kind of innovation so
my view is yes we need to the state has
a role a critical role in Chiao in
meeting this Russian and Chinese
challenge but we can only do this as
Americans by doing what we're good at if
we try to do something we're not good at
like industrial policy we will fail at
it even if on paper looks like a good
idea which by the way I don't think so
but we can't innovate and commercialize
better than anyone else and if the
Chinese are spending tens of billions of
dollars to build a chip fabrication
plant so we come up with a better way of
doing it suddenly they'll have a hundred
billion dollars worth of worthless chip
manufacturing plants on their hands and
you can't predict the outcome in advance
you have to make the commitment and to
have a leap of faith that American
ingenuity and science will be the answer
we can win this but we have to win it as
Americans in the American Way thank you
very much
please raise your hand in the mic we
brought to you
you say that Islam is failing could you
expand upon that for a moment please
Oh Islam is a culture that goes directly
from infancy to senility without passing
through adulthood and I mean that in the
literal sense every Muslim country that
has achieved the equivalent of full
adult literacy has experienced a rapid
and sudden demographic collapse Iran is
the great example of it this is a bit of
my Tomic but since you asked when Iran
had its disastrous Islamic Revolution in
1979 Iranian women on average had seven
children now it's about 1.8 it's the
fastest decline in population growth in
all of recorded history and what it
means is that as this generation retires
there'll be nobody to support them
you've got Iranian pension systems were
already where there are more people
receiving pensions than paying in in how
long that's gonna last so Iran in 2025
years is going to have an elderly
dependent ratio higher than Germany's
with 1/10 the per capita income which
means they'll implode Turkey ethnic
Turks are having fewer than two children
the Kurds are having three children
they're having twice as many children as
the Turks we did a study at this at the
Defense Department and concluded that no
matter what assumptions you put into the
model by about 25 years from now the
majority of old Turkish citizens under
the age of 30 would come from Kurdish
households the Kurds would no longer be
a minority that's why the Turkish
government is bombarding our ex-friends
the Kurds in northern Syria because
they're terrified of a breakaway
occurred a state of course if they came
to their senses they'd realize the best
thing they could do would be allow the
Kurds if they wanted to does
carve had a state in the impoverished
mountainous southeast and not fight them
but they're they they're they're not
sensible so you have countries like
Pakistan with illiteracy of fifty
percent would still have four children
per female they can't feed themselves
they can't produce enough electricity
they have chronic power shortages they
have environmental disasters they're
subject to perpetual chaos and you have
countries like Iran and Turkey which are
suffering from demographic implosion
it's the poles of infancy or senility so
I don't see any of the major Muslim
countries achieving a successful
transition into modern economic life and
they'll be in a perpetual perpetually
chaotic state that's what I mean by
Islam is dying the case of Iran once you
get literacy you don't get a lot of
Islam Iran is one of the least Islamic
countries in the world on the least
religious kind of like Russia in the
nineteen eighties where there weren't
any communists except in the Central
Committee Iran's rate of mosque
attendance is estimated at four or five
percent unfortunately the religious
loonies are the ones with all the money
and all the guns but it's a very
unstable mess and I think we put our
mind to it we could crack that regime
like an eggshell
you're right on regarding the research
background that we need to have in this
country to go forward
I spent a career in research at General
Motors and I remember working very
closely with Bell Labs labs at GE and
Westinghouse who are now virtually gone
and so I wonder what your perspective is
in terms of corporate investment today
in R&D that should keep our nation
strong and innovative in the future
corporate R&D includes a lot of things
like you know making a better class of
cornflake which doesn't have a lot may
be good for people like cornflakes but
doesn't nothing I'm not disparaging it
but it doesn't have anything to do with
national security I don't know the
tragedy is we had great research
organizations like Bell Labs RCA labs GE
Labs and so forth which really don't
exist anymore and it was understood that
some of your best engineers would serve
out their time do something innovative
then they could find it saying a star
throwing company so you'd have a
conveyor belt really coming from DARPA
with the high with the most advanced
physics research going into
commercialization so the one thing I can
say is that we don't corporate America
is gonna have to reorient towards that
there are things that we could do to
give them a little bit of a shock for
example I mean I'm again I'm a free
trader I'm a free market guy but as
president Owen said this morning the one
thing that supervenes is national
security that's when we postpone our
pursuit of happiness and stand shoulder
to shoulder and defend ourselves one
thing that dr. Kressel and I advocated
in the Wall Street Journal piece I
mentioned was domestic content for
defense goods it's outrageous that were
flying warplanes with Chinese chips any
sensitive goods should be manufactured
in the United States now we could do
that by executive order and you know the
first thing that would happen the Intel
and Texas Instruments hadn't
raytheon would all come to the Pentagon
and say listen for years he told us cut
costs so we moved our supply chain
offshore we did what you told us to
now you're telling us bring it back
onshore see that's what I'm saying slick
and they'll say you damage money that's
gonna cost us we fear quite a lot that's
gonna cut into our profits well we'll
give you costs plus 10% they're not
gonna like it
first people will scream about it we'll
be the corporate sector but if you use
the power of the American state to
require certain kinds of activity as a
matter of our existential security
interests you'll change corporate
behavior real fast may not be good for
some people's stock price you've got a
lot of screaming it can only be done by
a strong president and a strong
Secretary of Defense nothing else is
going to do it can't set up a commission
gotta come for the top do you see do you
see China making an aggressive move on
its colony Hong Kong to further suppress
its democratic instincts absolutely not
as a matter of fact my office in Hong
Kong overlooked these student
demonstrations across the street from
the from the government offices in
admiralty in Hong Kong this was a
middle-class rebellion by students who
were very dissatisfied with their
economic prospects they were very
careful not to get themselves into
trouble because they all wanted careers
they were not they are gonna die for
democracy it's very limited in its scope
and in Beijing or Shanghai the attitude
towards the Hong Kong kids was they're
sort of spoiled upper-class kids and
they've got all these privileges why
aren't they happy with what they've got
the Chinese don't need to suppress it
and that movement is not a real threat
Hong Kong is very important to the
Chinese for a simple reason China never
had a system of laws
the Emperor was the system of law is I
tell you to jump and you ask me how long
to stay in the air
China has British law so a lot of
companies including major Chinese
multinationals do their business out of
Hong Kong because their counterparties
require Western law no threat to them
and it's very useful so I think status
quo is what's gonna happen in Hong Kong
very very good presentation thank you
I'm from Michigan and we currently have
a Sharia compliant running for governor
the Democratic ticket we are involved in
a very activist program to educate
people about Sharia compliance and when
you say that the countries are not
reproducing our feedback here is because
we're getting so many immigrants coming
from those countries they're rapidly
increasing their populations here
praying that they're gonna have for any
kids they've all got four wives and the
people here really know nothing about it
that your optimism about Islam is
interesting but I don't think that's
gonna prevail healer in the United
States
well I strongly support the president's
merit-based immigration policy and I
think if that's implemented that'll go a
long way to solving our problems
[Applause]
returning to China is that China has had
a couple of policies kind of a two-prong
aspect of it
what is the one-child policy which they
have liberal eyes a little bit more
recently and the second portion of it is
that the retirement system was always
the mail they went to the fam though the
parents went to the mails family
therefore they didn't need females and
there were some of that genocide of
those two prongs there what is the
long-term impact on China and their
culture from those decisions that's a
terrific question no one knows the
answer I think at a 50 or 100 year
horizon China may be in very serious
trouble demographically they now have a
two-child policy we haven't seen any
change in fertility behavior since that
change though it is assumed one thing
the Chinese figured out under the
one-child policy is that since it's a
winner-take-all system there are only a
very few slots at the top and everyone
fights ferociously to get into those
slots it makes sense to concentrate your
resources on your one princeling and
prepare him or her for the University
exams and aim for maximum success so for
example there are a hundred million
class the music students in China this
is paid for of our private tuition those
parents have figured out or they believe
I think correctly that getting your kid
playing piano or violin helps academic
concentration is good overall having two
children makes a little bit more
difficult so fertility behavior may have
changed permanently in which case China
will be in demographic trouble at some
point its workforce is going to start to
decline probably in the next 10 years
there are probably a couple of hundred
thousand Chinese that are not counted by
the census who were born mainly in the
countryside say in the 1980s just
weren't registered so it's not quite as
bad short-term as it looks but long-term
your point is
very well taken now in the meantime if
China is able to mobilize its one belt
one road system they can solve labor
shortages by outsourcing though for
example they've just built a couple of
fast railroads to Turkey they could put
components on a container bring them to
a plant in central Anatolia have
inexpensive Turkish labor assemble it
there and sell it to Europe there are
several hundred million people in
Southeast Asia who are have Asian values
they work very hard they believe in
education a lot of them are really not
integrated into the industrial economy
but they could be so from the standpoint
of where the United States stands the
Chinese demographics is not going to be
the kind of liability for China in a way
that enters into strategic calculations
at a 25 year horizon longer than that it
could be China's Achilles heel
you didn't mention anything about the
connection between China and North Korea
and they're not deterring North Korea in
their EMP
endeavor to take the United States out
is China going to take a any interest in
that China wants to play arsonist and
fireman at the same time they've
encouraged the North Koreans quietly all
of the North Korean missiles used
Chinese components or components
delivered from overseas by Chinese
companies about a year ago the South
Korean navy fished North Korean booster
rocket out of the ocean put up a
satellite they recovered the the booster
and that found was full of Chinese
components so we know that the Chinese
are doing this no the Russians are doing
it too and then the Chinese can say well
aren't we being helpful by trying to
help you deal with the North Koreans
it's a way of you know getting leverage
over the United States the Chinese want
to have a nuclear war with the United
States no why should they do they want
the North Koreans to take us out I don't
believe so because that's the kind of
thing that might lead to a nuclear
exchange
and they certainly hope to win without
fighting are they playing dirty ball
absolutely my view of what how we should
respond to that is by instituting a
crash program for space-based missile
defense we should have the capacity to
shoot down anything the North Koreans
put up within seconds of its being fired
now that's something that Chinese and
Russians will not like at all
because we've refrained from doing that
on the grounds that it would be
provocative in other words if we were
able to stop the Chinese and Russians
from shooting nuclear missiles at us
that would give us supposedly the
capacity for a first strike I don't care
if they like it or not
they've got no business telling us how
to defend ourselves and that was what
Reagan division with SDI except we
didn't do it technology has improved a
great deal we certainly could do what
our current missile defense is pathetic
so I would like to see us respond to
that by scaring the pants out of them
and putting up a fully capable space
face missile defense
[Applause]
a one thing you have in common on
commented on is the economics and how
China goes on affording this they've
styled themselves for a long time as
being a socialist economy but a
politician that we're all very familiar
with at Hillsdale once remarked that the
problem with socialism is that sooner or
later you run out of other people's
money do you feel that this applies to
China and why or why not well the
Chinese are not socialists they are a
dynasty trying to maintain its power and
will use whatever means they can the
Communist Party is the state point it
could be communist fascist or anything
in between
the ideology really isn't the issue take
the case of Jack Ma and Alibaba
certainly one of the great companies in
the world
matter of fact Jack Ma bought the little
investment bank I was working for and
and fired all of the Westerners which is
why I'm not working there anymore
so if I stock in it by the way he's a
great intrapreneur but he is joined at
the hip to Xi Jinping and the Communist
Party for one thing they want to
encourage the consumer they want to keep
the consumer happy and Alibaba like
Amazon is doing a great job of that
they're great at microfinance but
remember the Chinese have massive data
on everybody Alibaba and all of these
companies are hardwired also into the
Chinese Ministry of State Security they
know everything about you in China they
know they'll track your cell phone at
all times and they'll make sure you're
carrying it by using facial recognition
and though in real-time crossbred that
against social media postings and online
purchases and financial transactions
they have capabilities for social
control that Hitler and Stalin could
have only begun to imagine and the great
entrepreneurs of China
get to be super-rich by becoming
instruments of the Chinese state as well
Huawei is another terrific example so
they certainly want to harness the
efforts of Chinese who wish to get rich
and use their creativity and they've
opened things up to them have allowed a
lot of people to get rich while at the
same time making sure that the interests
of the state and the Communist Party are
paramount these guys know that they
could be liquidated in a heartbeat if
they get out of line now it's a very
different system it's not socialism at
all it's it's China being China where
they will copy elements of Western
capitalism and integrate them into a
kind of social control which we as
Americans find horrifying we have time
for just one more question I'm sort of
surprised but I haven't heard more about
India I would think they pose some
threats as well as some opportunities in
India world's largest democracy friend
of ours very high growth rate but India
has a number of obstacles to overcome
that prevent it from being in the same
league as China by a long margin and one
is that they've done nothing about their
infrastructure they still have the same
railroads the British built over a
century ago
China's totally transformed their
infrastructure my hometown of New York
looks like a third-world City compared
to Shanghai or Beijing in terms of
infrastructure they have the world's
largest high-speed train Network they
have excellent highways airports look
like science fiction sets India
infrastructure is catastrophic and
that's because their political system
has been unable to centralize the
resources to make that happen
they also have a cancer system they are
not a meritocracy you're born into the
lower castes you basically stay there
forever and old future generations so
India has hundreds of millions of people
living in the most dire poverty
illiteracy you know really primitive
conditions of life and there has been no
effort like this this Chinese migration
of the cities the 600 million people who
moved from countryside to city the vast
amount of construction and
infrastructure that's required to
receive them Indians have done nothing
like this
they haven't even attempted it'd be
great if they did but India as a
strategic factor is decades it's not
centuries behind China thank you all
very much
you